democrats are retiring in large numbers
and i got to tell you i think it's
meaningless it certainly just means
other democrats can run in many of these
districts and probably win and even if
republicans end up replacing them it's
no guarantee we're going to get any of
the issues that we want solved solved be
it inflation be it's coveted or be it
things related to you know epstein
evidence unless people start voting in
the primaries unless people
run in the primaries
otherwise what would we get more
establishment politicians just get more
democratic just it opens up more
opportunities for a big giant red wait
what is what is a euphemism for the
republicans taking over uh congress that
doesn't sound like a female menstruation
administration a red wave in
but hold on too look 11 republicans have
also retired and then we got devin nunes
is resigning
what do you make of that because i have
argued often times that trump has shown
very little loyalty to people
what do you make of devin nunes
and and i love cash patel i love the
work that he's done devin nunes did a
lot of good work on the russia thing
what do you make of devin nunes being
the lead
in battling the russia incident with for
on behalf of trump
in congress and then retiring from
congress to take a job with trump in a
billion dollars you know a corporation
two billion or whatever is it a billion
yeah i have no idea but i'm just
euphemism i don't know what do you make
of that nothing
nothing just normal well i mean it's a
guy taking a job it's it's devin nunes
and he's doing what devin nunes does
you know i think it's interesting that
he's resigning and he's going to head up
this media outlet whatever or this media
opportunity social media
but but what of it
was was that what is that to say yeah i
don't know i in my mind it was actually
just an opportunity where it seemed like
you know trump was showing loyalty to
somebody but oh sorry off time was it i
uh oh it's trump's truth social or
whatever yeah partnering up with rumble
i mean it's good to see that there's
going to be this infrastructure but
they're partnering with rumble yeah
trump's yes trump's organization yes is
going to partner with partners it might
not be the exact right i don't know
they're organizing with distribution
it's a distribution deal
interesting trump trump's trump's media
company is going to use rumble for their
distribution they're doing a
distribution deal a distribution into in
the sense of like it's going to be
branded rumble or it's going to be like
an aws type thing where it's like
providing videos the infrastructure will
be rumble's infrastructure for trump's
but it'll all be branded trump whatever
it's going to be i i think it'll just be
a video player on truth social it's not
going to say trump anything like when
you go on twitter the video player
doesn't say twitter on it right so
truth media is going to need videos and
they're going to use rumble to do it so
that's that's partnering for their the
video side of things that's a lot to
process it's huge it's huge it's it's
competition now i've been saying for a
while that you know uh republicans got
no ground game and i still think that's
true but this is important so i guess i
can say to your point about devin nunes
in the face of what's happening with you
know with with the democratic party i
think they're running scared because
they know red wave is coming devin nunes
joining this media venture there was a
news article that said it shows you
where the true seat of power lies or
something like that and i'm like yeah
who disagrees with that the media is
more powerful than a politician many of
these politicians including republicans
care more about the opinion of the new
york times than they do their own
constituents so nunes goes to truth
social social seeking to build influence
and counter silicon valley and rumble
and trump are doing this because they
realized they got no ground game going
out waving little american flag saying
vote for me ain't going to cut it you
need to create and spread culture and
ideas
i i'm surprised it took them this long
to figure it out
they still really haven't figured it out
yeah i know they absolutely have to
figure server is going to shut them down
the isp is going to block them get ready
guys you're or like you said vanguard
state street black rock gonna buy up a
public shares of it i'd be like ban
trump off the platform and they're gonna
get voting shares and a lot of people
said yeah well rumble hasn't given up
voting majority i'm like that doesn't
mean anything
you know
it it's it's it's it's frustrating
because
hold on let me read this right here it
says stocks of special purpose
acquisition companies cf acquisition
corp that's the thing that locals merge
into rumbles merged into this publicly
traded company says that it says it will
now have count trump as a member on the
platform
that's a little bit different than
what source are you looking at that's
yahoo.com uh what we we had we had a
source on this the other day and it said
they were partnering for distribution
interesting truth social
maybe where maybe it was wrong
i remember reading what you were talking
about tim yeah we were talking about
service agreement
agreement
with trump's truth that's social this
rsbn says rumble and trump's truth
social media platform strike major
distribution deal yeah so i i use rsbn
because they're very much in the trump
you know side of things right howard
lutnik the ceo of rumble's parent
company of counterfeit steroids
announced monday a groundbreaking deal
with trump's new platform truth social
lutnik said in an interview truth and
the president are going to use rumble's
infrastructure technology their cloud
distribution capability so they're going
to be a service provider a tech provider
to the president's truth social in the
sense that aws provides these kind of
services to other companies as well and
and that's and that's what that's what
dave was telling me that rumble's plan
was was to become aws in that sense
do you know how long it was from uh
locals selling to rumble to rumble
selling to effectively selling to canter
fitzgerald about 36 minutes
36 days
which means dave likely knew what was
happening and i suppose you can argue
that it's all a good thing and i'll tell
you this upon learning about the
institutional investor getting in i have
some worries because like we were just
mentioning now that they're public yeah
the bad actors can find a way they can
buy their way in and keep buying their
way in and it doesn't matter if you have
majority shares or not people don't
understand how the stuff works there's
there's things called hostile takeovers
but
seeing this massive infrastructure now
starting to emerge i'm like i'll take
what i can get man if this is countering
the the the official like silicon valley
oligopoly this is better than than maybe
i think of it as like if you're a farmer
in poland and then the the russians are
coming from the east to to
across your land maybe they're going to
destroy your farm maybe they're not but
now if another army springs up we're
we're gonna counter and defeat the
russians this is rumble uh and they come
from the west now you have the germans
and the russians meeting at your farm
everything gets annihilated yeah but
that's not necessarily true because
what's gonna happen here is
they're both going to be colliding in
the field turning to you and say join us
join us sign up for my platform sign up
for my platform you're going to be like
uh who's going to offer me the better
deal yeah ian historically russia and
germany teamed up and invaded at the
same time against poland and my people
so i think you're
the armies can get bought up by other
armies and
i see a lot of good here i see a lot of
good here um with what's going on with
rumble and all this stuff because now is
institutional power
in opposition to the oligopoly of woke
leftism it is a very
uh veneer of power it seems like power
it feels like power but in a moment that
switch can be flipped and it can be gone
and i think that's that's
completely it's beyond the company being
sold i think
i'm not going to trust centralized media
companies like social media companies
they're
truth social and all these places have
the right to ban you the same as every
single other platform people have
pointed out terms on trump's website are
not too dissimilar to other websites the
difference is will will the ideology of
truth social be beneficial to you versus
twitter's crackpot ideology yeah for all
of us here we probably better off on
truth social however they'll probably i
mean they'll ban auntie for left and
right and probably right and rightly so
because they're violent and they
advocate for violence
but are they going to end up being
biased in favor of the right i would not
be surprised if that was the case will
it be as bad as left no because the
right tends to be in my opinion more
principled to their own detriment
we're going to see that again in that
axios thing we're going to talk about
it's creepy stuff though but but look
look look i was really hard on you know
rumble and locals and all that stuff
yeah and that was because
you know we didn't see the full uh the
full plan i'll put it this way when
locals was uh first of all um i'm not a
fan of patreon or any of these platforms
locals included because they're
centralized people should have their own
platforms it should be decentralized
network tech so they all can come
together it's not hard to do and that's
what we should be striving for in my
opinion so that no one can be banned but
if you're gonna provide a service like
you know dave rubin did i've got no
qualms about that i just feel like it's
not advancing us
then when they sell to rumble i'm like
that seems like exploitation that seemed
like rallying a bunch of contracts
selling off to a company then we see the
spac deal where now it's basically going
public and i'm still not a fan of that
however upon seeing this massive growing
infrastructure i'm happy to see it
emerging because at least it's
countering the other side that doesn't
mean it's a good thing it doesn't mean
people aren't going to be exploited it
doesn't mean bad actors won't eventually
find their way in it just means i will
take an alternative a strong
a strong alternative with good
infrastructure is a net positive and it
would be hypocritical of me to say it
was a bad thing because i'm constantly
saying why aren't people doing this why
aren't they challenging this
encountering it so that's great however
i think the solution in the long run is
decentralized social media yeah there's
incremental steps to take there's long
term steps to make with the liminal
order we're always constantly looking at
different uh communications options and
one of the strategic challenges i'm
faced with as a business owner as leader
of this network over 800 guys now uh is
do we take a step that is like one step
forward two steps forward or do we wait
for that thing that's like going to be
20 steps forward and and and the reason
why at this point we have taken the time
to we're being very patient uh to not
take two steps forward is because uh if
you're familiar with the book who moved
my cheese this is a management book
about like moving the cheese just ruins
everything for everybody like if you
change people can't handle change and so
if we're going to go through the process
of change and we've talked about this
before of like moving from one platform
to the other from patreon to subscribe
star or whatever if you're gonna do that
it better be for something that is an
absolute slam dunk grand slam that is 20
steps into the into the future that's
going to last five to ten years that's
not just like an incremental baby step
and perhaps it feels as though that
locals in this rumble thing is like baby
baby steps not the quantum leap that
perhaps you guys are working on and so
it's both of them are are important
though because there's new people
entering into the market today that are
going to want to take t plus 2 that
aren't us sitting here at t waiting for
t plus 10. what i'm saying rumble should
take the money they get from the spack
and start subsidizing all of their
creators that way
people can say well i could be on
youtube but rumble pays comparably so
why don't i just go there the challenge
right now is it kind of does but the
views aren't there which means rumble's
got to subsidize that and say if you
make a video on youtube that pays a
hundred bucks you make the same video on
rumble you get paid the same amount
incentivize even with like a tenth of
the views right yeah or we'll pay you
more just be like how how about this
like they've already done it with
several key people like you know siraj
hashmi and glenn greenwald they need to
do a lot more of that russell brand
they got russell brand they signed him
didn't he sign with locals i don't know
familiar with locals did i did i miss
that i don't know that i don't know if
that's rumble though
well it is yeah no i'm saying it doesn't
it doesn't mean that it doesn't mean
that russell brand is putting his
podcast on rumble he's on youtube right
i see what you're saying thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you